already in paying their bills and in
October those bills those energy bills
are going to go through the roof up from
just under about two thousand pounds to
3 500 pounds then up again in January to
4 200 pounds and many people are going
to really really struggle so we have a
choice we either allow the oil and gas
companies to continue to make huge
profits whilst every family suffers or
we do something about it we the labor
party are not going to stand by we've
got a fully costed plan that says we
will keep those prices down we will not
allow these Rises to happen and we are
going to have a windfall tax on the oil
and gas companies to pay for it and that
is the right compromise because we're
standing with those people who are
struggling to pay their bills what about
in the longer term if we get to say next
winter in the price Cap's still at you
know four thousand pounds or thereabouts
what then well this plan will take us
through this winter and there are so
many people that are anxious about
what's going to happen in the Autumn
anxious that they can't pay their bills
so this is a real answer a costed answer
to their the complete opposite of what
you got from the government was saying
absolutely nothing true it is that in
the midterm and the long term we need
other plans that's why a year ago I said
we've got to start insulating our houses
properly bring the bills right down in
the first place and make a massive
difference but we also need to
absolutely have a Sprint on Renewables
like solar on tidal and or wind so that
we're not perpetually in this situation
we need to make sure we're not so
reliant on the international market
which is driving these prizes would you
continue with the plan though if it is
the price cap is at four thousand pounds
a year and how would you pay for that
well look we've got to assess the
situation in April when we get to the
situation in April but the question I'm
answering is what are you going to do to
help all of those households that are
going to struggle so much during the
course of the winter and we've put a
costed plan saying we'll hold those
prices make sure they don't go up over
the windfall tax on oil and gas
companies we're making huge profits they
didn't expect to make to pay for that
complete opposite of what you're seeing
from the government you've got Boris go
is saying I know there's a problem with
Energy prices but I'm not going to do
anything about it you've got the two
leadership candidates quarreling with
each other an internal fight about just
how bad their recording government has
been when people are we are stepping up
and actually putting a fully costed plan
on the table that will help people
through this winter is it enough do you
think when people are really struggling
well we've been talking to people this
morning about how they're going to cope
through the winter and they are very
very pleased to hear an announcement
that says we're not going to let those
prices go up so this is across the board
they're going up significantly aren't
they it's a radical plan well Andre plan
they won't go up that's the whole point
the fear is that if the government
doesn't step up the prices were the
average will go up from two thousand
pounds or so to 3 500 pounds then up
again to 4 200. you only have to say
those numbers I'm sure many people watch
them saying I can't afford that kind of
money so we're saying we'll hold that
back we won't allow those prices to go
up and we'll make sure that those that
are actually making a lot of profit out
of this pay for holding those prices
down and that is the sort of plan and I
think you know people are very very
receptive to